[Musique]
il se passe des choses dans les foyers
russes qui dépassent l'entendement des
histoires atroces des hommes qui battent
leurs femmes surtout en toute impunité
une culture patriarcale bien ancrée au
pays des gestes que la loi tolère en
silence ou d'un groupe quand tu me diras
que les aubistes d'effritement
zenia zahrach ne compte combien de
femmes sont passées dans son petit
studio de tatouage depuis quatre ans
déjà elle leur consacre tous et lundi
pour tenter d'embellir irréparables aux
des cicatrices qu'elle refuse
gratuitement lire ici qu'est l'écoutent
avec sang froid
la première fois que mon mari m'a battu
il le tenait ma fille de 4 mois dans un
bras et me donnait des coups avec
l'autre il était ivre et s'est énervé
pour en rien je vous supplie de me
donner la p tite
mais ils savaient très bien qu'ils
pouvaient me faire chanter avec les
enfants n'ont plus cette jeune femme que
nous appellerons vous elle a mis huit
ans avant de demander le divorce
quand elle a dû appeler la police quatre
fois plutôt qu'une
li les agents sont venus pour repartir
quinze minutes plus tard c'est la norme
d'abord il répond vous devez régler vos
problèmes entre eux et ils te disent on
a des vrais crimes ans étaient ils ont
ans d'études que les femmes sous la
pression de la société ou de familles
pourraient tirent leurs plans vous est
là aujourd'hui le corps couvert de
cicatrices et de brûlures elle nous a
demandé de les cacher de peur que son
ex-époux la reconnaissent car il n'a
jamais été arrêté cette dette
genia exagère à peine
et de plus en plus de femmes en russie
se mobilisent pour le dénoncer
nos aînés l'avocate alona popova mène la
charge pour le droit des femmes
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'elle tente de
convaincre le parlement russe d'adopter
ces mesures concrètes mais plutôt que de
sévir contre les agresseurs les
autorités ont décidé au contraire en
2017 de décriminaliser la violence
conjugale et d'en faire un simple délit
sauf difficile dans les circonstances de
dénombrer les victimes
même les cas de féminicide sont souvent
traités comme des accidents ou des
suicides
la loi stipule d'ailleurs qu'une
personne doit être tout au moins
hospitalisé avec des blessures graves
pour que son conjoint soit menotté et
accusé au criminel le cas de margarita
world sheva en est l'exemple au cul mais
nous répondons de ses cauchemars
nesterov côte basque au 11 décembre 2010
est son mari l'a traîné dans une forêt
en banlieue de moscou
au lieu de la déposer au travail il eu à
couper les 2 mains avec une hache un
drame
inimaginable qu elle documente
courageusement dans un livre consacré
aux femmes victimes de violence et votre
mari et elle nous raconte avec un calme
désarmant que la violence et les menaces
de mort avaient commencé quand elle a
demandé le divorce quelques mois plus
tôt elle avait même supplié les
policiers de le tenir à l'écart du foyer
familial
mais ça n'a rien changé à son triste
destin le 7 décembre les policiers ont
décidé de fermer mon dossier le 11 mai
mans était tranchée ils n'ont rien fait
ils n'ont même pas essayé
il aura fallu cinq chirurgies pour
recoller une de ses mains des mois de
physio et une prothèse pour remplacer la
deuxième et la voilà aujourd'hui sont
les grands plateaux télévision russe
empreint de militer pour l'adoption
d'une loi tu les groupes de pression ont
convaincu le parlement d'étudier
encore une fois je me rends compte que
je suis devenu le visage du débat sur la
violence domestique empêcher les gens me
connaissent et se rappelleront toujours
de moi je veux en profiter pour demander
un exercice de relations publiques
plutôt rare dans un pays où on préfère
ne pas se mêler des disputes familiales
un pays où l'église demeure un obstacle
majeur à l'adoption de toute mesure les
gars nous étions à la cathédrale saint
sauveur du christ à moscou quand
l'église a convoqué une assemblée
extraordinaire pour manifester son
opposition au texte de loi que le
parlement et qui dit cette loi et en tue
mais anti familiale anti religieuse et
anti tradition un complot venus de
l'ouest les gens qui comme margarita se
bat pour une loi sont des ennemis de la
russie et de la famille de cette femme
cette hausse nous explique comme si
c'était normal que si un mari frappe sa
femme dans mon nom je veux dire et je
sais qu'elle l'a probablement margarita
ne perd jamais son cas même pas quand
cet avocat sur le plateau télé lui
demande qu'est ce qu'elle a bien pu
faire pour provoquer son mari navires
neufs tout avait-elle une âme et
communications secrètes avec un autre
homme
alona pour pauvres a été là et secoue la
tête
voyez dit-elle contre quoi on se bat
discours que guzel connaît trop bien
pour l'avoir entendu toute cette même ma
grand-mère méduse est toujours en voyant
me bleux jambes dures et mon mari tu va
endurer le tien tu n'as pas la première
il lui a fallu tout son courage pour
partir du foyer s'installer chez des
amis et recommencer à zéro
photo de tatouage douloureux mais c'est
un moment de grâce dit elle un centime
en liberté n'ont cessé en butte aux
folles
[Musique]
margarita aussi apprend à vivre seul
mais la peur n'est jamais loin son mari
a été condamné à 14 ans de prison mais
pourraient sortir dans cinq
s'il se comporte bien et elle crie que
même d'ici là la russie n'aura toujours
pas adopté les mesures nécessaires pour
assurer sa protection et celles de
millions d'autres femmes qui souffrent
en silence sous leur propre trou